if khadija was this why who are you
telling me that i cannot be this and
and the easiest refrigeration is that
she hired the prophet
seven other men to go do the work that's
the whole story
these sisters they need to wake up
khadijah was not the type of woman to go
and mix with men go outside blah blah
blah you know business this and that ceo
no
did she have ideas for business was she
running it yes
did she do the muscle work no study the
seerah
study of the hadith before you talk okay
because it gets you in trouble
[Music]
doubts honestly aren't always bad
because
if you're doubting something like
logically speaking or even if it's like
something that has to do with morality
once you find the answer to that it
boosts your iman even more
because you you don't just get this
feeling of okay
i'm neutral again you get this feeling
of i can't even believe i doubted that
bro
and then you become even closer to islam
assalamu alaikum and welcome back to
the with this podcast in the dunya i'm
your host rami
with your other host fayad and
unfortunately we are
one man down he is m.i.a but insha allah
we have
amazing brother gabriel to make up for
that insha allah and this is a
continuation of the intimacy series
probably one of the most important
series
we are starting or uh we are continuing
actually
even though you may not understand the
wisdom until you watch it so go check
out episode one
if you have not watched the playlist up
till now
in previous episodes some of which i
wasn't a part of but you know
and now we need to talk about you know
how do we actually maintain a marriage
because it's one thing to get married
and have a good you know day night
week and then marriage actually hits you
and now you're living with a person and
you have to not only maintain this
passionate love
but you have to learn how to be merciful
towards someone and to maintain this
attraction so
how exactly would a person especially
men who are supposed to be the leaders
how would they go about something like
that
the most gracious most merciful just
let's uh
take a step back and review what
happened in our last episode we talked
about marijuna and i think that episode
was really
alhamdulillah important because there's
many mistakes that are done till today i
receive
messages from people uh
you know counseling that oh my god i did
this i did that wrong and this would
happen you know it kind of leaves
um a couple in in trauma if they don't
know what to do and they don't know how
to react to each other it's supposed to
be the most beautiful night of your life
right
kind of like you've been waiting for
this your whole life some people wait
for a long time
some people get married there's one
brother here
one of my clients last week and
you know we were counseling and he was
trying to get married and i said are you
you've never been married before he's
like never
meaning he's a virgin right allah but
that he's a good
man he's you know like from a good
family so he's virgin
and he's 42
you know so imagine you're waiting like
okay let's say since you have puberty
like you know about
i mean like you know 20 30 years you
know pretty much waiting
uh to get married right from the time
you hit puberty so
it's uh it's very tough you know
i think a lot of when i was in india
living in the arab countries
there was a huge problem with women
being you know in their 40s
and virgin not married you know so
some people subhanallah cannot get
married today is we make it very
difficult i think society makes it
extremely difficult
um recently i was talking about desho
maher
and posting some things about my heart
you know and how difficult
some parents make it on their children
to pay
hey you know the guys just get upset and
be like you know what i don't want to
buy your daughter
your daughter like i'm out right but
it's a reality
right so it's difficult to get married
finally you get married
and on your marriage and it's supposed
to be the nicest most beautiful
night you just bonding you know it's
like it doesn't work out and
subhanallah you know um again basically
i'm just just kind of
extracting some numbers some statistics
from my counseling
i would say that about 80 percent of the
marital problems
are linked to the lack of
or or problems with intimacy right
and people say like why is that you know
like
thinking about intimacy all these sex
the most important thing your life
and all these questions that are
illogical
and it is because i mean
intimacy is the the bond between
a husband and wife right now that's what
allah tells us
he's put between you love and mercy and
love you know we used to call intimacy
making love right it was an expression
of love and i think today
i think we said it before with the
popularity of pornography and of the
loss of hayah
and the propagation of a lot of this
fashion evil things that you see
throughout
that a lot of muslim people in general
are separating the two
love is just like emotions you have to
cry and i need to
get hugged and this and that right and
that causes a problem too because
that's the way the women interpret love
now it's like
you know if man wants to come to his
wife and be intimate
she'll say stuff like oh that's all you
want from me you just want to have sex
right
i just want to cuddle and you think i'm
right all
no but it's like that's the way most men
express their love and it's it's
i think yeah there's a corruption of
that
behavior and that response but
in general there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be intimate or making love
with your spouse like that's what you
want right
and sometimes you know the ones i just
want to cuddle and i just want i want
you to love me and like the man says but
that's what exactly what i want to do i
want to love you and she's like no but i
don't want you to love me that way
and it's weird because you know i think
i think sometimes women also have to be
a bit
they're not so honest when it comes to
this because when they get you know
um when it's the ovulation period they
also get
they they come very uh hot on right and
then
the guy like he it's not like the guy is
going to be like i just want to cuddle
you know i just i just don't want to be
loved
we're ready we stay ready men are pretty
much
ready all the time but there's
like this contradiction right like women
if they don't feel it they don't want to
you know kind of you know respond but
but when they feel it then men have to
respond
all the time right um and we are weird
so strange strange very strange that
i noticed this pattern now in my
counseling that
a lot of women now complain that men are
not able to
to respond now these days it's like it's
swish like i have
i have some clients who are you know
like divorcing they're they're taking
hola they're taking divorce they're
going to the sharia courts
and the art the the issue is that my
husband
is not sleeping with me and it is it is
a reason
for divorce the
scholars if the man does not
fulfill his duty of pleasing his wife uh
in intimacy
then he the the judge can dissolve the
marriage like there's obviously there'll
be some counseling though it's not just
like alt
like just like that and that's what's
happening but in
in general if that's if that issue
continues then the
judge can order for example the man to
go to the doctor to check himself
all these steps are taken cause a lot of
times sister says sisters don't
understand right
they always blame islam and they say
like we're left alone no one cares about
us we're always suffering men always get
the best of it
and you have to understand this
statement is made within a a
frame of a non-muslim system in a muslim
system
a woman
can go to the court and
raises issues in sharia court and the
judge will entertain these problems
and will you know uh force them in by
law
to go to a doctor to get counseling and
all this and he can be punished if he
doesn't
or you know the judge will and you know
uh will just dissolve the marriage
so i think women also have to understand
that but going back to the main point
that is that intimacy is just so
important
it is the the bond and imagine
what comes out of intimacy pleasure yes
that is one thing
but that event
generates love and affection
right generates intensity passion
right and yes it is it is carnal as well
but that's the whole point because you
have two physical bodies coming together
so no doubt islam is not about you know
monk type of philosophy
it is carnal but because we are human
beings and
that's exactly what we are but what
comes out of that
bond what's generated is this energy
this
love and passion and compassion
yes one quick sec so uh i think angel
just didn't get our message
because we sent it on whatsapp so i sent
it to him on imessage and he's here
so i'm gonna just add him through okay
but uh
so and that energy
is so needed
for for what for children
for family like if you don't have that
energy between husband and wife
if you don't have that bond being there
subhanallah psychologists talk about
the effects of the lack
of love and commitment
and passion between
spouses between husband and wife in a
healthy family
and the lack of that can result in a
negative upbringing of the children
lack of emotions understanding
of and so on that is something that is
very important because people think is
it just about sex it's not just about
sex it's about love it's about emotions
it's about
passion which generates energy
love energy emotions compassion
which is felt in the household
which in turn in turn affects the
children and their upbringing and their
emotional
uh intelligence right so when when
children
see the father and the mother hugging
and kissing and you know
i'm not talking about something you know
extra but i'm talking just a normal
right
holding hands just seeing and the
prophet saw selling would hold
his wife's hands the prophet sallam
would be you know
very open about his love for example
when he was asked he said i love aisha
you know
and that type of love is important so
when the kids see it
they will grow up to to appreciate that
to do the same thing but when children
grow up in an environment where they
never see
the child the the parents interacting
and loving each other
then that will have a huge impact on
their
development and what they would do
especially if they grow up in an
environment
where it's always fighting and there's
always you know there's physical
issues and problems and then screaming
and whatnot
then of course this is going to affect
them so yes
this is so important and yes that night
that sets the standards that we talked
about last time i hope people go and
visit that episode once again because
it's so important
that night is the most important night
when it comes to marriage
because you set the standards right so
but the question is now how do we how do
we maintain
the the sparks right i think that let me
see it let me say three things
so first thing uh they missed the
message but they they had stuff to say
about the eggplant emoji
so i just want to let you guys know that
just because of that i'm gonna add
another eggplant emoji for the next one
second thing is it's it's it's only
about sex is what they say until they're
ovulating
right then it's then you know we're
always ready it's about sex
selective selectivity yeah third thing
bro i just wanted to say assalamu
alaikum
my uh my uh phone is charging he has
like two percent battery so
i'm not gonna be speaking all right bro
get no worries
bro what's going on oh yeah
let me ask all three of you a question
i'll let gabriel go first then the other
two
if you had to pick one thing what is the
number one single
first and foremost important thing for
maintaining that spark
just one thing okay i think you have to
say one thing i think to maintain a
spark
yeah i think i think uh communication
really
yeah all right i'm gonna say sex romney
[Music]
found a lot i was gonna say uh the
demeanor of the man
to be honest
hold on let me let me connect with you
quick
i was gonna say it's a mix a mix between
the three of what you guys said
yeah i can't say anything like
specifically any of them are more
important
uh listen if it was me i'd say sex is
most important
but honestly like communication is super
important
the demeanor is super important like if
the man doesn't hold his frame then you
know it's not gonna happen
right but then if the man is not
communicating with the girl it's also
not going to happen
and then if the man's having sex but
then isn't doing good well then
that spark is not going to happen either
so the key is to communicate to her ear
while you're having sex with her
while holding frames simultaneously
that's a dangerous combination bro i
think i think anna's answer's the best
bro
but yeah gabriel let's say you have
couples coming in now we don't want to
hear any names obviously we're going to
keep it confidential because of the
counseling you do
what are some of the most frequent
causes that you can
prescribe or diagnose two people that
come to you and they have dysfunctional
marriages
okay all right so subhanallah recently i
was
targeted by some interesting people to
say that you know
the the counseling that i do is not real
i'm making these things up
and blah blah blah you know and it's
like my god you know like these people
you know if i come to like this this is
this is my
my black book of counseling you know
this is where all the all the all the
different cases you know
uh that i write for every client you
know
like i mean it's there's hundreds of
cases here okay
where i discuss and i write you know
their
notes well i listen to them
you know people actually are not ready
if i were to start pulling cases from
this
book and start going into detail i think
people go like they'll be like no wait
this is like
sci-fi you know no way right
and it's because like i don't know i
think we're just
i don't know which planet we live on or
what's happening why are we denying
reality
why are we lost is it is it life in the
movies or what
is the media that we just feel that
things are just on tv
i'm not sure but this stuff is real okay
this stuff that your podcast talks about
that we talk about
this is real stuff you know what i mean
and yeah we can pretend that we're
something different and talk about
things that are important as well
and many brothers do that mashallah but
i think
that's what we agreed that we're just
gonna be what you guys said the realest
podcast in dunya right it's like let's
talk about
like real stuff so
but let me just really before i answer
that
why i chose communication because that's
where i see from my counseling that
there's a
disconnect so starting from marriage
night
um if the guy doesn't have any clue
about what he's doing
or he tries to pull perform something
that he's seen for the past 10 years
while watching pornography or sometimes
the girl believe it or not she will
she'll shock him he sometimes it
happened that he's a nice village boy
and she's like you know a wild cat and
then he comes to me and he's like bro i
don't know what to do i'm shocked
you know like it happens it happens you
have guys who come and say
i can't hold it longer than you know
like a minute
right but but my friend told me it's
okay like it's normal he does the same
thing right
and then but my wife wants me to go for
20 minutes right
and i think she's crazy or i think she's
asking too much and
it becomes a it's like sad you know but
there's a disconnect in communication
because they they don't communicate till
the offense has been committed till they
feel sour towards each other
till they you know they really have
already
told family or friends and it's you know
disrespectful
and there's a lot of resentment a lot of
things that cannot be undone right
when someone starts talking about you
and disrespecting you like that it's
very difficult to forgive them
so if you dedicate so the woman for
example
cannot reach climax most women will hide
it they will lie about it at the
beginning
because they don't want to hurt the
husband right
but if you don't communicate to the guy
that look man
it's it's not working right like can we
try something different
then it's not gonna work and if the guy
is not willing to accept that
communication
so i have some clients where you know
like those say like but i want to try
different things or i like something
different but he doesn't want to listen
you know he just wants to do his thing
or the guy would say she wants to just
do her thing or you know some guy
she's like one one client said my wife
is like like a piece of wood you know
he's like he's like that's that's all i
can compare it to just a piece of wood
so what do you want me to do with a
piece of wood
so but then when you listen to the to
the lady's side then she'll say
well he's like he's got no wood you know
there's just you know it just does so it
depends like
that's a hard part and our job is like
you have to listen to both sides and
subhanallah
most of the time the story takes a 180
tournament when you listen
to the other side you know but i would
say
communication like if you can
communicate and say look
honey i got you know i just didn't feel
this or i just
i didn't like this or i don't know the
way you behave was not good
or you know i don't know the way you
smelled or the way you
acted or the way you know you've you've
approached me or what you said to me
how about we try this that's where the
problem is i think
you know by nature by fitra we are
wired to be intimate you know i don't
think
anyone doesn't have the ability to be
intimate
the external factors that cause
us to not be intimate or to get away
from it run away from it the blocks the
psychological blocks
the resentment the problems that reduce
the frequency and the intensity and so
on and
if not addressed like there are couples
who have not
had intimacy for eight years 10 years
and so on imagine that
living together and sometimes you asked
him but like why are you doing that
kids or for you know for the community
or the family we don't want to
feel bad like they did something wrong
like they got us together certain
cultures like people come together they
arrange the marriages
so the the kids don't want to hurt the
the parents
you know with the divorce and so on so
communication i think
is so important i think if we can teach
premarital
courses and counseling and focus on that
you guys have to express
you know the way you feel about intimacy
you have to agree before because it's
it's quite
weird right if one of them after you've
had your first night
turns to the other and says by the way i
wasn't able to
like it's nice that you are you i i feel
happy for you
but i didn't you know i wasn't even and
most of the time zapana is the woman who
doesn't you know because
she's biologically designed different
allah has designed women
when it comes to this quite different
right and
for men it's a bit easier not always but
it is a bit easier
okay it happens also when men are not
pleased okay it does happen
but it's usually the women who don't get
pleased it requires a little bit of
extra
anatomy to for the man to understand
like how to please his wife right
just a little bit of knowledge it's not
that difficult but
if the woman is going to turn to her
husband and say like look you know i'm
happy that you've
had a good time but you know no i wasn't
so
satisfied most likely he's going to be
upset he's going to be hurt
but imagine if you could prevent that
imagine if you have gone through like
two weeks of counseling where you
discussed this issue that hey guys this
might happen
you know are you guys ready to talk what
would you do if that happens
how do you respond how do you talk how
do you you know how do you try again
you know how do you express those those
feelings and emotions without hurting
each other
i think it would it would solve a lot of
problems now you don't have to get into
like
details and whatnot when you train but
just to raise the awareness that this is
going to happen
you know and you need to talk about it
and i think if that's the case the first
night let's say
and trust me most people
it's amazing sex in the first night oh
my god is so like
most people do not for most women it's
traumatic it hurts
it is like you know very very you know
not good it's usually after a month or
two months where things get a bit you
know
more easy and more comfortable that
people actually start enjoying
or the woman starts enjoying intimacy
but at the beginning
it's usually not and the man is very
reactionary because he's been waiting
for this for 10 15 years or whatever
right and he kind of rushes and he
cannot control himself
and yes he can cause trauma as we said
or
you know it just leaves her hanging so
coming
the extremely extreme to continue to
facilitate intimacy to to have to
you know two people laying next to each
other and cuddling and hugging and
talking and
expressing feelings i know it might
sound like uh you know but
it is very important it is very
important intimacy is not just about
banging
and just you know performing and doing
this and that
that is usually what pornography
destroys you know the idea of intimacy
when it comes to the fitra
so i think that is the the most
important but going back to your
question bro for my counseling
as i said um most people have
no clue as to how the other people feels
right or how the other one feels so like
i had a client recently who said
that finally when they're about to get
divorced
okay after like nine years his wife says
to me i've
only climaxed once with you you've never
taken once in nine years bro do you
understand
and how and the guy said i feel so hurt
because like i mean we should
right i should say like come on yeah and
the other thing is subhanallah you know
what he said he says i wish i would know
what you guys are talking about because
he said he's a convert
and he said when i converted to islam i
said i'm not going to do the things
you know so i just like kept it like you
know just like
one way you know he's like i'm not going
to do the things that i did to like you
know inja helia too um so
i was like bro but that's not you know
because i thought this is haram and this
haram this haram this
i thought just missionary just you know
do it and that's it finish right
and it'll be like done right and i was
like subhanallah
and again this is right yani um
you know it is ignorance and as this
you know that the ignorance is an enemy
to himself
right if you if you don't know and it's
not necessary's fault that again
people don't talk about these things
yeah alhamdulillah we have books but
sometimes these things are buried like
people do not
talk because they think it's against
things it's not good
i agree that you shouldn't be like
overly and you know
have lack of other good manners you have
to have good manners
but it's such an important discussion
because people are
suffering so i'll be very honest guys
couples who come to me for counseling
one of the main
things i asked him at the beginning how
is your intimacy
right and then maybe one asks me like oh
how much did you spend on her or didn't
i straight up go for how's your intimacy
right and then i they get shocked you
know like oh well
i'm like just it's just a normal
question i said are you guys intimate
how how often and how is the quality
and it's always man people who have
marital problems
okay it's always bad it's always
non-existent it doesn't happen like
last time we were intimate four months
ago four months ago
four months ago yeah four months ago
well because she doesn't
she doesn't want to talk
i don't want it's like you know four
months
how is intimacy well you know like two
minutes one minute just kind of you know
let's just get it over with and that's
it you know
yeah get over it right so i'm like so
what's the so then when we finish the
discussion
your mother said this and you didn't pay
me that
and you know all these things disappear
right
they're not a big problem they're
actually all these things have been
amplified because the two are not close
anymore the two broke the bond they're
not talking they don't love each other
there's no emotions remember what i said
right
that that family that you know the house
is called
second or from
and that emotion that the energy is not
there because intimacy is not there
making love is not there right when you
make love you produce that energy
right when you when you are when you've
made love to your wife and you're you
know
you just like you want to hug even if
you're moving around in the house you
know
you're always like there's a different
you're relaxed
when you're not intimate right if you
look at it you're always on the edge
you're always you have this extra energy
that's
built in you and that can turn into
to amplify the problems oh why'd you
look at me like this why'd you say that
why you know something so small can
become something
huge oh you're late to me or you didn't
pick up my call no but my phone was
there
no i think so i think it's you know it's
panalla
right so all these small problems become
huge
right now i'm not talking about that
people have no other problems other than
intimacy
but what i'm saying is that when when
intimacy is good you can solve other
problems man you can
think differently you can be straight
you can be relaxed you can
you have a lot more logic and reason in
your in your mind that when you're
lacking intimacy and you're suffering
for like the past four months
right so i think it's key
for for people to let me ask let me play
devil's advocate there's
there's a quick thing that a lot of our
viewers are going to say let's say they
get married they want to just have good
maintenance game for their marriage
and they want to have a good sex life
but they watch porn and they develop
this thing called
erectile dysfunction that you always
talk about so you know we don't have too
much time but
what is a quick fire you know i guess
summary of how they can overcome
erectile dysfunction aside from just
time
okay so erectile dysfunction is is is
kind of linked to a to a mental issue
right
so your mind has been conditioned to
react
in a certain way to a 2d
model right because usually when you
watch porn it's on the screen
so it's 2d so when you're you know when
you're with a 3d model
like a woman then your body your mind
doesn't react the same way so
the mind is is where it all starts in
and then your body reacts right
and that's where i think um i was
reading an article where uh
the owner of playboy right
yeah right okay they said that he he
just
he had all these beautiful women around
him but he he was only able he would
have to watch porn and masturbate
to be able to climax like he wouldn't be
able to actually
um you know be with these women and
that's something that you know they
reported for
for a long time because you saw it was
all about the screen it's all about what
he sees and what he
like magazines are 2d as well exactly
so i think the the quick fix for that is
there's a lot of anxiety associated to
lack of performance so let's say the man
is not able to perform he has
erectile dysfunction and um
obviously he's going to feel bad about
it the woman depends on how she's going
to react
right she can say it's okay honey don't
worry or whatever she can just turn
around and be upset
so it depends and that's going to be a
a a reinforcer for next time right so
because he failed now
next time he's about to perform he's
going to have that anxiety what if i
don't get it up again right
so that's actually going to turn into
him not being able to do it so it's
going to keep
doing this so basically a solution to
that just to relax
is for men to focus on different
techniques other than intercourse
to be able to remove i think we talked
about the the pressure of having to
perform or you know it's basically you
can please your wife with other
techniques
and once you climaxes once twice it kind
of relaxes them and then he can now
do his thing and again with
communication
and so on the woman affirms that she's
been pleased and you know that she's
been pleased if a man does not know that
his wife being pleased then he's got a
problem okay if the woman can trick you
and can you know fool you that she's
climax or whatever just to
let you go then you should be you know
you're not understanding your
your wife's body language and you know
and the way she
so if if she communicates to you she
tells you look take it easy i understand
the pressure
and there's been a lot of articles where
you know that relate this kind of
treatment
where couples talk and you know there's
there's patience and
there's other techniques that we talked
about in the previous episodes that the
man can please his wife
and she can basically climax and she's
happy satisfied
and now she focuses on him to help him
to kind of you know get it back and of
course cutting the porn just stopping it
that's one of the huge things right your
brain starts realigning and readjusting
to the actual real situation the 3d
person that's that's next to you right
it requires a lot of patience from the
woman
understanding because a lot of women
when they find that their
husbands watch porn i must say that
like women are a bit more um
i think that they stick around a bit
more but i think things are changing
though right
so when women catch like men for example
like cheating or watching porn
they tend to stick around a bit more and
keep trying to make it work out
but i think things are changing now um
and a lot of women when they catch their
husbands being addicted to this or
doing something wrong they they tend to
now ask for divorce or to leave so it's
increasing
right i think women are losing their
passion or things are changing around
in the world they're being pushed
they're being uh encouraged to leave
at the first problem and
yeah so i think it requires a lot of
patience a lot of discussion a lot of
understanding
and the men to just realize i please my
wife in many different ways other than
just intercourse then intercourse can
slowly come
cool i think that was a phenomenal
answer bro
for anyone watching if there is
something really important that you want
to book brother gabriel we'll put a link
in the description for a counseling
session
feel free to reach out to him but i
think this is just under five minutes
for brother rami
so if there's anything that rami wants
to say bro let it be known
yeah so um you mentioned communication
when it comes to maintaining
marriage um but what else is there
because as angel mentioned you know
you can communicate everything right but
that doesn't mean that everything else
is up to par
because perhaps communication is not the
issue um
maybe there are things that she's
communicating to you that you haven't
worked on so what would you say i guess
is the second most important thing
okay so to maintain a
healthy intimacy life and healthy
marriage
after communication i think
everyone has to kind of work on
themselves right like
um if the man takes care of himself and
the woman takes care of herself
if they understand each other's roles
and you maintain
the frame of the family and the guy
maintains his masculine frame and the
woman maintains her
feminine frame organically the two will
continue
having sparks the problem is
that in most couples
being influenced by where
[Music]
um there's this unnatural unhealthy
competition that starts
once they get married so work
a woman wants to work she wants to prove
herself that she's also
worthy and so on and again we talked
about work many times but it's not about
that it's about
sometimes she's not understanding her
priorities so she's stepping out of her
feminine framework
and the guy is going to have to
compensate for that so he's going to
step out of his masculine framework
and things become unnatural they're not
organic anymore
the woman is going to slowly slowly
become more masculine
he's gonna have to wear pants
or what do this or rush every day or
come late or
things i'm not just speaking of work but
what i'm trying to say is that the guy
starts sometimes acting
less masculine a woman is feminine the
guy doesn't take care of himself anymore
so he loses masculine framework
he doesn't work out he doesn't you know
i mean it was
recently an article saying that oh
working out is toxic masculinity and
forced and blah blah you know man should
not work
out right all these silly things
yesterday i posted from the guardian
where this lady this feminist was
picking on tall buildings saying this is
a sign of toxic masculinity building
this is
the buildings looked like erections and
they were spraying and i looked at that
i was like
subhanallah bro like how how
disrespectful bro that
how could they make those buildings
without thinking of the woman's fragile
you know
sense of femininity
i mean but but it's it's it's becoming
ridiculous isn't it i think it's it's
i think we've reached a point where if
these things make it to mainstream media
it's ridiculous right but what i'm
trying to say is that imagine that kind
of woman
what kind of men does she have or does
she even have a man so what kind of
relationship will it be right
because again there's always when when
someone moves away from their position
let's right now it's the euro cup right
i'm just watching the the summaries of
the games i'm not gonna lie people can
get whatever i like i like football like
i grew up
playing football i play semi-pro i love
football you know or soccer whatever
so i watch the the summaries of the
games you know three minutes
okay but uh imagine if
if the midfielder moves to the wing
too much right or if the sweeper
leaves this position what's gonna what's
gonna have to happen
actually what happens is naturally
someone from another position will have
to compensate for that
area that's not covered right
and which
results in the team suffering because
that person now let's
say if the sweeper is moving the the
right right defense or left will have to
compensate or
the midfielder has to come back okay
so the team is going to suffer because
he's left his position now that's what
happens in marriage if
if the woman starts acting and not
feminine doesn't take care of herself
doesn't you know beautify herself
anymore right
she doesn't pay attention to her husband
a lot of women start focusing on the
kids once they have kids only on the
kids i'm not saying you shouldn't focus
on the kids right it's very important
but
many women make this mistake that they
get addicted to
and they leave the husband they don't
sleep in his bed anymore and all that
and if the guy is not going to pay
attention to the girl
he's growing a big belly he starts
smoking whatever he's losing his hair
all these things right she's not
attracted to him anymore he doesn't act
like him anymore so
they're both losing masha'allah
here we go there we go bro so
they're both that's the one
they're both they're losing their
position right
so naturally the two are not going to
work
together the team is not going to
perform well it is what it is like just
look at families man if you look at
families who are having problems and you
ask them
this question is the guy the provider is
he the one who
is the imam of the house is he the one
who
makes decision is he the one who's
assertive i'm like oh no well you know
i'm tired i'm this i'm that
whatnot and you asked the woman are you
waiting for a husband when he comes home
are you pretty are you taking care of
yourself
well you know i had a couple of kids now
and you know i gained some weight like
how much weight like you know like 50
kilos extra i'm like
what you know wait a second why are you
allowing yourself to go to that point
well you know chocolate is good and i
have to have energy and you know these
kids
i'm stressed and you know if i eat ice
cream it just helps me why not
like yeah these are excuses so don't you
know once you leave your position
in the team that's it the team loses man
that's it it's just though it's just
it's just the way allah has made this
universe to work that
every person has to stay in their
position
maintain the skills for that position
polish the skills for those four for
that position and keep working on that
to make sure that they are
meant to be and that's omar khattab
would be very careful on who he selects
for specific positions the right person
for the right thing
you know what i mean so yeah
you know you actually remind me of
something my teacher was teaching us
yesterday he said the formula for
victory
is is unity and and skill set
so being unified having unity and uh
knowing your skills and working on your
skills to develop them properly
it's final law so essentially what
you're saying is we must maintain our
frame
and work on ourselves and at the very
least maintain what we have but always
strive to be
better inshallah very important there's
a wonderful
line from uh brother mahdi that i wanted
to show brother gabriel
that women marry men in the hopes that
they will change
men marry women in the hopes that they
won't change
interesting i need to i need i
need to analyze that i don't know
analyze it bro
look into it bro i think i think i think
uh
if a woman marries a man in the hope
that he will change
i think she makes a big mistake i mean
that happens i mean it might be a fact
it might be a fact what he says but i
think
it's a big of course and and men
thinking that a woman's going to stay
the same is also biologically you know
it's a big mistake but it doesn't take
away from the fact that men still marry
women hoping they'll never change and
women still marry men
hoping that they will change that's true
you're right
100 man 100. um brothers have to go
unfortunately
so uh insha'allah i look forward to the
next one
[Music]
we're more covered than half the women
these days bro
anger bro uh send me your address bro
i'll send you a nice one inshallah
you can join the team man
but i was um i actually ordered one
today
wow yeah i gotta i'll send you a picture
of the one that i ordered but
um if you want to send me one bro i'm
listen my hands are open
yeah yeah send me addresses
inshallah i'll show you some pictures
then you choose one then i have quite a
few still
all right inshallah we were speaking
yesterday
that we might start like a theme for the
podcast we're just gonna we're just
gonna show up like you know
actually i like the mix with the with
like the just like the jersey or
whatever and the
it looks it's cool
[Music]
i think a very important part as well is
uh
men gotta know what they want in a woman
and women got to know what they want in
a man
you know understanding like the reality
of what it takes for that to
to be you know like if you want a woman
to be feminine
you want her to be cooking um taking
care of you being affectionate
and being submissive and you guys having
the sex that you want to have like
it takes a lot from you as a man so you
can't just can't just sit around doing
nothing
and then expect that to be so i think
that's very important
no doubt not that yeah a lot of men want
the woman to be perfect but you know i
think there was one scholar said if you
want aisha you should be muhammad you
know
it's a lifestyle right yeah
important i think a minimum amount of
times that
and again it differs coupled a couple
but i think if you're having sex
less than four times a week three four
times a week i think that's a red flag
like every day at least once but if
every other day which is three four
times a week you're not even meeting
that i think
there's some issue wrong either you know
she's clocking in too many hours or
something because
i don't know people don't realize this
but women when they work they come home
they can't they can't perform they just
want to sleep men is different
i could come home from a long day 16
hours clocked in
bro let me make that 17 hours with you
i'm ready
but with a woman it's different she has
a finite amount of energy
but they don't want to hear that they
want they want to think they're equal
yeah it's not just about the energy it's
just the way their their mind works
right once they come home and they've
had all that stress
they don't feel that desire right men
for us it's like that's a manifestation
of all that stress you know men under
stress it's like a
you know cooker right it's like we build
it and we can take it out
in that way the more a man take that's
why he's built for outside that's what
he's built to be a
hunter gatherer whatever you know people
call it right like we're we're warriors
you know we're outside
we can put up with stuff we're stressed
and imagine you come home
and your beautiful wife is waiting for
you all that stress for all that
all those problems turn into this energy
that you just want to express it now
and trust me man she's not gonna she's
not what she's not gonna complain that
you didn't please me she's gonna be like
okay i'm done you know it's like
finished you know
yeah that's that's why most korean women
are not conducive to successful
marriages because they come home
and they've been ceo ceo ceo all day
it's like they can't turn that off when
they come home it's like they
think you know every woman can be like
where you know you can have a business
you can be a businesswoman ceo
entrepreneur then come home and
be submissive know your role in the
household but most women can't
if they're ceo mode all day they're
going to come home and they're just
going to carry on
and they're going to try to survive with
you it's amazing you say that i think
you have to cut this part from the
from the show and put it by itself you
know because
again someone some of these feminists
keep
using the model of hadith
right if khadija was this why who are
you to tell me that i cannot be this and
and again ignorance you know takes the
best of them
did not travel around with the caravans
and go and do the business
as people think they didn't go then the
easiest refutation is that
she hired the prophet seven other men to
go do the work
that's why and that's how she proposed
to the prophet selling that's the whole
story
that she hired him and he went on a
business trip for her
and her servant told him of his good
character and what she did and then she
proposed and what he did and that she
proposed it
she was in her goal yeah of course she
would be a respectful woman
many men try to marry her she wasn't
having it
and you know and she saw the you know
muhammad who you know pulled his weight
and did things
properly and mashallah she was impressed
she was not the
these sisters they need to wake up
khadijah was not the type of woman to go
and mix with men go outside blah blah
blah you know
business this and that see or no was she
a wealthy woman yes
okay because she inherited and she was
smart yes
did she have ideas for business was she
running it yes
did she do the muscle work no did she go
and mix with the people in the market
and do on this no she hired muhammad
salla
and other salah study the seerah study
of the hadith before you talk okay
because it gets you in trouble
okay people need to relax these women
always just this morning subhan that's
why i wanted to come this morning i
received
you know this fight from this feminine
oh look khadija did this and this
you need to
when you're dean you need to know and
khadijah at that time
she had the process she was just on a
fitra she was not even muslim yet
you know the prophet saws did not
receive revelation here and she was
still acting like a proper woman
you know what i mean so subhanallah
people need to
people need to be cognizant of that i
think that's what you're getting at and
people are forgetting the fact that
gender roles is really a thing in islam
because it's it's obligatory for a woman
to take care of the house
and it's obligatory for a man to provide
so why are you
letting go of father and worrying about
sunnah yes you can work but it's sunnah
that should be secondary
and for a man yes doing household stuff
is sunnah but
you can't just be at home and not
providing so that's why i'd never be
with a woman that wants to work
full-time it's just not going to work
because women can't do that they can't
work if you want to work full-time and
take
hold the house down be my guest but you
can't do that no woman can do that
so guys with that being said if you made
it this far
hashtag housewife and hashtag
marriage game because unfortunately
today there's too many women doing
overtime at work and on the time with
their men
and you know last but not least sorry go
ahead go ahead
yeah i was just gonna say and peep this
uh women being at home
you know taking care of the household
taking care of the kids taking care of
maybe
some like creative type of business not
like a business out where like they're
going hard like
this is a different type of stress right
this is a different type of stress than
the stress that's uh
placed upon men and women outside in
companies and their own businesses like
really having to go hard and like we
said a man will take that stress
and literally just unleash it on the
girl
and it's like that stress just makes us
want to do that for a woman
if she goes out there and she
accumulates his stress all she wants to
do is release it by complaining
and telling you how how much her day
sucked
or sooner or later she'll be
accumulating something else from some
other guy
but with that being said um i know tons
of women
like for example my wife's mom she's
like a seamstress right like she's like
a tailor so she
she has her own business she works at
home and she's she's holding it down
she's she's doing everything here
but you know there's other women that
are like oh i want to do something like
that too
like something with my hands like the
seamstress thing or i want to do like
art
but it's like it doesn't stop there
they're like okay now i want to go on
these art expos or competitions now i
want to
you know like be out of the house six
months out of the year like
bro what that's not what angel's saying
i know saying like cultivate that
creativity but channel it in a way where
you're in the home and you can like
hold both things down and the farther
they're still there you're still holding
the houses down but
you're still productive you're so
self-employed you're still
self-sufficient
you're not relying on it for money
because you know your husband already
has it you're doing this just to give
some type of value to the world
and just feel fulfilled doing something
with your life
right that's real man and and what
happens is out of that lifestyle where
both of you are outside there's there's
this this
scheduling that takes place right and
you become very regimented
and intimacy becomes regimented okay
honey
like you know it's like okay friday is
our night or
this night or you know it's like you
start scheduling
and that just kills it
because intimacy if you look even the
hadith of the process
you know there's three times for
intimacy during the day which could even
be interpreted as you could have
it three times a day right and
uh it also it should happen naturally
right that's what the apostles
said he said even if you're on top of a
camel and the man
wants it he told the woman you should
give it even if you're cooking on top of
the stove
if the man wants it you should give it
that's right so i mean these these
hadith are very
when people look at him they're like oh
i think it was like interpreted
okay you interpret it for me you know
what do you mean when the process them
says on the back of a camera like
at that time they were writing camels so
do you know what that means right
what is the
men have this time where it just happens
you know it's it's natural
we don't be like yeah uh wait it's it's
time now okay let's wait you know like
it's
it doesn't work like that it actually
that's one of the killers of intimacy
and and and or the lack of is when you
become
so scheduled and so it's like a job
right oh i have to be at work at eight
so let's do a quickie before you know in
the yeah what is this
five minutes i mean so it's gonna kill
it
yeah this is this is airing on your
youtube channel too so i'm gonna put
some some men on game
two that are that are your viewers and
your subscribers that you should never
be 50 50 with a woman
you should never be providing 50 and the
woman provides 50
because 50 means it can't work without
her that means if she doesn't work
the family won't thrive or even survive
and women don't want that pressure
think of it like a table all right well
we all have a table next to us right now
table got four legs right two for the
man two for the woman
now if the woman goes out what table do
you know
that can stay standing with two legs it
cannot
a table needs four legs at the very
least it needs three legs so if a man's
giving at least most
if the woman pulls out which is the the
one leg the table can still stay
standing
but with two legs i don't know a single
table or chair that can stay standing
with two legs
so 50 50 will never work with a woman
it's too much pressure on her
she never like she'll do it if she has
to right and that's why society and this
whole materialistic world is moving
towards you know inflation and you
needing two parents
but it's not the best scenario just like
a woman who's says she's single
independent strong i'm 30 i have my own
business
can she be okay of course she can be
okay but we're still better together
you know a woman who can take care of
herself is better than a woman who can't
but she's not as good as a woman that
has a man you get me
so similarly yeah a man can be happy in
life
just without women you know you can
still be rich he can still be successful
but
he's not gonna be as good as with the
woman
right we're better together there's no
competition between men and women that's
what
women have to have to be aware of yeah
yeah i think the social dynamics that we
are witnessing today are conducive for
people to
to live alone like we used to be
dependent on each other and allah
created us
you know he created the woman from the
man he created adam and eve
they were together for thousands of
years the
people were depending on each other men
depend on we need women
and women need men right but now
you see the way this the the society is
structured
that if a woman wants to just go she can
go
there'll be support for her subhanallah
if a man
wants to be alone he can just spend his
life with prostitutes and with
porn and stuff like that i know what i
mean like there's all these
weird things that have happened in the
past few years
that have destabilized the family
because the family
used to as you said be together it's
it's a union it's it's something that
it needs all four legs you know to be
healthy
and remember that it's the building
block of
of the nation of humanity and that is
why i believe it's targeted
that is why if you look at a government
level there's all these
all these programs that encourage
sometimes people say but that's not our
intention our intention is to support
but you're encouraging
okay people to just quit
throwing a towel as soon as they can i'm
not saying here that people have to stay
in relationships that are
bad and toxic and whatever that's not
what we're seeing but
if you're looking for me as a counselor
i see that at the
first bump man people are willing to
throw in the towel right away
because they know that there's always
something that's going to support them
here there they can just do it on
themselves and
or just do it themselves or just do
themselves or whatever you want to call
it
right and they're just saying hey i just
go my way i don't oh i don't
like it you don't have
if you don't have let's just say if you
don't have an alternative to something
right you're going to think twice before
leaving a job for example right
you're going to think wait a second i
need i need i need my job i got to take
it easy wait you know
but if you got like let's say you know
you're a rich spoiled kid
and you're in this amazing job and
something doesn't go your way like i
quit
i quit because you know you got
something to fall back on now
you know that's that's not always good
man that's not always good because it
it's cultivates that type of behavior
i quit i quit i quit i don't like this i
quit i just walk away
no we depend on each other we're
supposed to work things together
the whole system of the sharia and the
family is set up to solve
problems to keep families together
you know so that's oh you you know what
hypergamy is most men don't know what
hypergamy is right so it's like
men don't have that we're not gonna you
know like
if we're okay bro you could be making
100k a year
and marry a girl that works at
mcdonald's bro and we'll be okay
women won't do that most most men would
prefer that probably most men prefer
that exactly
women women are going to make 100k a
year and they're going to want a man who
makes 200k a year
women's gonna be six feet tall you're
only gonna see them with guys that are
six foot one or taller
you know women want men that are better
than them women marry up women they up
women only sleep with
up they don't want men that are about
the same or under
that's why this whole thing about i want
to work on myself
and be a queen it's it's like you could
be a queen but you're not going to be a
queen without a king
like a man who marries a queen he's he's
just like a queen's
prince you get what i mean like he's not
really a man but then
if a woman who's nothing marries a king
she becomes a queen
you get what i mean women aren't women
can't become queens without a man
so they need the king
bro you froze i think it's not quite
cold
in my salon
no no you cut out are you left
bro long story short like
a woman cannot make a man a king but a
man can make a woman a queen
because a a woman who's a queen trying
to be
all that trying to be up there chasing
the corporate ladder if if she marries a
guy
who ain't anything he ain't ish he's not
a king bro he's just like a woman's
like the queen's husband or the queen's
prince in a way he's still like a little
boy
but if a woman who works at mcdonald's
or whatever she marries a king
she becomes a queen a woman's is only as
as high as the man that she's with
that's why there's this thing about this
myth of a high value woman what is a
high value woman there's no such thing
as a high value woman
a woman's value is equated to the man's
value that she's with but a man's value
is not acquitted to the woman that she's
with
that he's with a man's values who he is
what he is what he's done in the world
right so at the same time women you want
to get a degree
you want to go to school we're not
telling you not to do it but get married
first
because if you get a degree you get that
master's you get that phd
your pool of viable candidates is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
so you're going to be a 30 year old
woman with five cats saying why are
there no good men
where have all the good men gone you
missed out you have a biological clock
the way allah designed you we don't
we have all the time in the world we
could be in our 40s and we haven't even
peaked yet
it sounds harsh bro but um
and and i feel like why can't you be
sensitive why can't you care about us
sisters
girls we do this is why i'm telling you
these things because i care society's
not going to tell you these things
society wants you to find out when
you're too late and you're dried up and
you're menopause and you got six degrees
and you can't find a good man
i'm telling you this now so you can take
pre-emptive measure
we're trying to give you the truth yeah
we're trying to give you the truth bro
turned off all of mecca you know upside
down and you got so much hate
you know i'm like you can't be a person
and i'm not trying to compare us to the
prophet
not even close but we're trying to give
you the truth and when you give the
truth
it sounds harsh but i'd rather give you
the truth that's hard to deal with now
and then over time long term it gives
you ease rather than society giving you
ease right now
okay so right now you can go out
clubbing you can go only fans you can
start your business whatever you want to
do
but long term you're going to suffer so
here's what it is
yo i'm still thinking about um what you
what you guys are saying how like uh if
the guy
is on the camel and you want sex then
you should give it to him i don't know
yeah and i'm thinking like you said oh
if the girl is cooking
and and the guy wants sex then like she
should give it to him i'm like whoa whoa
whoa hold up now
if if any of my girls are gonna be
cooking like i'm not gonna mess that up
i don't play with my food
because we can do it afterwards after
you're done cooking after we're done
eating all right let's go
let's get to work what about during you
know when stuff simmers for like 10
minutes you got that like 15 minutes
you gotta let it simmer that window nah
nah nah i'm gonna let her
sit there and be focused on the food
what are you gonna be doing meantime
we'll be watching her
watching the food right here we go i'm
i'm managing the girl who's who's
cooking
exactly i'm the supervisor while she's
cooking here we go supervisor
i got to make sure she's putting the
spices that i like
and i got to make sure she's taking the
time out just to make it extra crispy if
i want it extra crispy
hey hey babe do you want to cook
together uh nah babe i'll supervise you
while you cook
i'm done and at the end of it be like
hey babe do you like what we made
together and she's gonna lose it
oh man women are fun bro women are
it's supposed to be easy but life's not
supposed to be hard for all the men
watching
if life's hard you're either a bad with
women or two
with a bad woman that's it it's supposed
to be simple
i like that with that being said brother
gabriel romani
joseph every time tomorrow we're filming
part nine but this is part a for the
viewers uh
do comment down below what you guys want
to see any feedback
this is definitely our longest series
that we've made
we are hitting double digits tomorrow or
the day or the
you know episode after so let us know i
don't think we're anywhere near the end
i think we have still a few more
episodes to bang out
but give us some feedback comment the
hashtags that i gave you marriage game
and the other one i gave you if you guys
really remember you're gonna write two
hashtags
i don't know you got anything else
i came in late so i i only know like
about the camera yeah so thinking about
the food man like listen
i ain't playing with the food bro hello
we got the other one which is tie your
camera first then put your trust in
allah
um i love cameras
i love cameras bro oh there's another
one with uh with
the process of some given hadith where
uh the camel urine
and camel milk uh are really uh
proficient in treating disease and i did
some research and
i found some scientific literature right
check this that
i'm talking about stage four or five
metastatic cancer like worst
type of cancer was you know the tumor
went down
with camel urine and milk fourteen
hundred years ago
prophet saw some said that but today
they're gonna be like
here you wanna drink camel urine that's
so barbaric that's so backwards
but they'd rather pay you know 500k
chemotherapy lose their hair
um you know another thing me and angel
learned was apparently in chemotherapy
you can lose your hair within a day
we didn't really know that but a lot
apparently
a lot of protect man i mean
um i already drink some camel
yeah same bro
[Music]
doubts honestly aren't always bad
because
if you're doubting something like
logically speaking or even if it's like
something that has to do with morality
once you find the answer to that it
boosts your iman even more
because you you don't just get this
feeling of okay alhamdulillah i'm
neutral again
you get this feeling of i can't even
believe i doubted that bro
and then you become even closer to islam
[Music]
[Music]